i've met some celebrities in my lifetime
yeah okay
and like i just did a movie and there
was a big celebrities in it like cate
blanchett was in this movie and stuff i
wasn't hungry it's called borderlands
it's coming out next summer but i play a
soldier but anyway i had to be there and
so i hung out with jamie lee curtis all
these people right but still when i see
howie i get more scared why because i
think i'm a fan of his uh-huh
right and i grew up watching him because
you know i used to be i used to
gravitate toward comedies yeah and um
he's going to be a compliment you told
me you're hanging out with kate blanchen
and jamie lee curtis you're you're
comfortable around them i make you
uncomfortable uncomfortable i just get a
little nervous around you because i'm a
fan can i tell you something what he
makes me nervous too is this energy
right it's his energy yeah yeah he makes
me scared he's a scary person for sure
he's great great having my daughter
my friends here because i feel good
about i give out negative energy yeah
it's intimidating energy it's not
negative so i do i'm a red carpet
correspondent and the person that scares
me the most to interview yeah is my dad
yeah i feel the same but that's because
the red carpet is in my house
and i go i just woke up enough with the
interviewing yeah
in fact i remember like can i just say
something no we want this should be a
broadcast with nothing being said okay
so um the first time i ever went to
montreal comedy festival was a couple of
years ago right and that's when you can
i say that you acquired the montreal
comedy festival all right so you know i
know him so finally i'm invited yeah
right so i'm no that's not true if you
want to go back you were invited before
and you always turned it down and you
told me i go why aren't you at jfl you
gotta go now i turned it down i know i
don't i lie
i lie i lie i lie
i lie here why did you so you turned it
down oh turned out a couple times i lied
and the first time you went though was
when when he got it okay right so then
um but i remember like one show that he
showed up at i had a heckler
but he was amazing i know but there was
a heckler in the balcony right
and i say two or three joke i know how
he's in the audience and i hear the
heckler go
[Music]
next
like that right right and
you take that as a negative that's a
negative oh okay do you think that's a
negative
i'm sure you hear that all the time dad
i i would even at home but in my head in
my head that they're watching you and
they're thinking this guy is next level
you didn't hear levels i didn't hear
that part yeah
i didn't hear that
but anyway so he says it and i go
i did there's the only thing to do in
that situation is to confront it right
you know i can't ignore it right
everyone heard it right so i just start
going
i've never been here before why would
you do that now we mendel's in the
audience i mean all that kind of stuff
right i think it may or may not work
that's your confrontation
yeah i know
i said he yelled next and i thought i
gotta confront it head-on yeah i just
gotta take it by the bull by the balls
and take it so i go this is my first
time here and how he's watching me but
that's not what you did yeah i'm not
good at conversation are you lying again
a little bit yeah
he is good you know what's funny he
doesn't like confrontation but he is the
most
the the first time i met you do you
remember the first time i met you uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was the
theo vaughn show
no yes it was
no what was the first time the was the
uh uh um uh what's the show on foxy ron
matt tv on mad tv that was the first
time you're right yes i lied again
a little higher it's very big on youtube
right bobby lee and howie mandel on
youtube you were naked i met you naked
ah
the cultures changed so i was
kind of i was half clothed
what is the culture what am i saying
well it's like because now like last
night i did a show at the brea improv
right right and um
i did a little dance in my underwear
right and then you dance in your
underwear yeah i had this cute underwear
on so you shared yeah yeah okay so i was
doing this little dance and then when i
got off stage my girlfriend goes
why did you do that you're like why
because she's just afraid that anything
like that can be mis
construed is that a word yes yeah yeah
misconstrued or construed isn't the word
it's misconstrued together construed yes
you know what i i did
my first time on stage the other night
my wife made me go on and i'm really
afraid now are you afraid because i okay
that's when i met bobby okay isn't that
me and that it it's gonna be he's
talking to me
that's the first time i met you are you
just always in cute underwear
there was a time where that that was my
go-to yeah
yeah okay
there you go
um
i remember that house
the sunset right yeah it was on sunset
yeah above the store comedy store
yeah yeah polly owned it oh he did yeah
anyway the point is that's the first
time i met you but but that is
emblematic of who you are because there
is no line which i love right you know
and that's i i we've talked before about
when i went to the comedy store my
favorite was uh richard pryor and i
watched richard pryor talk about
[ __ ] in his life you know he grew up
in a brothel and he was uh addicted to
drugs and he had bad relationships and i
watched him talk about that it was the
first time i noticed somebody but you
whether it was getting totally naked or
whatever you were like the most free
spirit it seems like yeah on stage
[Music]